college prep and career Readiness is a
Ponzi scheme they got your kid for 12
years they've already convinced you and
they have they've got 12 years to
convince the kid you need to go to
college because if you don't go to
college you're screwed and so you got to
go to college and what is that that's
that's just you got to pay a lot of
money to a school somewhere so that you
have a college degree and it's they're
in nowhere in school do they say why you
have to go to college it's just so that
you can earn the money but but it's it's
not like let's make a plan for you if
you go to this school it will cost you
eighty thousand dollars total over four
years and then you have this potential
of this earning no you can go for basket
weaving and get two hundred thousand
dollars in debt or whatever and you
completely unemployable and so my point
is the whole thing is at this point it's
just a Ponzi scheme it might be based on
data that came from 50 years ago but at
this point you know we got to wake up
and smell the coffee kids don't
necessarily have to go to college